Madrid City Hall has seen a change of
the guard in the last few weeks the
Spanish capital has a new mayor Manuela
Carmina she's a member of our aura
Madrid a citizen's initiative backed by
the left-wing podemos party her priority
is helping the less well-off in Spanish
society much like greases governing
cereza party Marta Gomez another member
of our Madrid also sympathizes with
serezha did then was mortal shell of
course we want to change things but we
don't want to do it recklessly we don't
want to scare anyone away with our
platform naturally will respect the
Constitution we're well aware what
that's for darling that was dented a
request roasters resolution Alice at the
podemos headquarters they're not
planning to take the policies of their
Greek counterparts as a template but
they agree on some of their methods not
a very much reflection angle we've been
thinking here at podemos about the kind
of economic strategy that we should
develop we see that the differences are
really significant and we should
probably take different strategies there
I'm not in this for you but apart from
that one thing is really clear giving
people the chance to express their will
on big political and economic decisions
publicly such as fire a referendum is
always a positive thing panevezys una
política siempre positiva but Spain's
ruling Conservative Party says podemos
is neither interested in democracy nor
capable of governing does from Morgan
lots of face anti-political models in
Europe that have no idea what they're
doing all they want is to use that power
to erode democratic institutions right
now Greece's syriza party it's just the
biggest example of this y el caso
monitor official the city sangria yet
podemos deputies take their work
seriously even if that's conducting
civil marriages rather than reshaping
society Marta Gomez reckons she can only
win people's trust by doing her job
properly after all not all Spaniards
agree with her about Greece's
brinksmanship
okay but if you're not Greece has to
make some changes but it's under too
much pressure right now see I've how are
they nice support Greece it shows the
kind of courage no other country has I
mean but I him to run on my beliefs is
up to no good it's not showing any
respect towards other countries after
her day job Marta Gomez holds an
open-air town meeting in her own
district to hear about the concerns in
her community they may be a long way
from Athens but perdimos supporters
still feel a close connection with Greek
people